[Musique]
jack médecine est né en 1979 à
scarborough en ontario mais il a grandi
entre le pendjab indien terre-neuve et
où il sort une jeunesse difficile car il
a été victime d'intimidation et
d'agression sexuelle
il devient plus tard avocat et se
spécialise dans la défense des démunis
et des immigrants jobs médecine se joint
au nouveau parti démocratique de jack
layton en 2011 mais il est défait aux
élections fédérales
il tente donc sa chance avec le npd
ontarien élu à deux reprises à queen's
park il devient même chef adjoint du
parti en 2017 il se lance dans la course
à la succession de thomas mulcair
il devient chef le 1er octobre mais ne
fera son entrée aux communes qu'un an et
demi plus tard après sa victoire à
l'élection partielle d'un but la vie
sauf en colombie britannique
[Musique]